and the left is already calling for
trump officials to be punished
first cnn made it clear the job
prospects for trumpers
are grim there are people in the
president's inner circle
you know the hope picks the dan
scavino's those types they're focused on
dealing with the president managing
his anger i'm told but there are a lot
of other people who are not
particularly close with the president
who are trying to figure out what is
their next job going to be what is their
next job going to be and what is it like
going into the job market
not from a normal white house where
typically you've got a lot of offers but
coming from the trump white house
even more alarming squad leader aoc made
this deranged call to action is anyone
archiving these trump sycophants for
when they try to downplay or deny their
complicity in the future
a former obama official actually
indulged her noting that he and some
former buddha judge staffers
were starting a trump accountability
list a political hit list
a black list of sorts courtesy of the
party of tolerance joining me now is
dinesh d'souza conservative commentator
filmmaker
dinesh the blacklist i mean you've been
writing about this for
decades the left has always had one
they they have and um and this is a
tyrannical impulse it's so ironic
because they keep accusing trump of
being a tyrant but ultimately
these are people who if they had their
wish uh they would
ostracize their opponents they would
have them fired from their jobs
they would have them digitally censored
and they cheered when that happens
and who knows they might next be willing
to imprison them
the historian david blight from yale
recently spoke about trump and the gop
as the new confederacy now this was a
very poisonous accusation think of it
first of all a member of the party of
the confederacy
is accusing the leader of the party of
lincoln of being a confederate
but i think that what he was trying to
do is sow the kind of hatred
that makes trump supporters into enemies
enemies of the country
and then this licenses in the name of
tolerance believe me
a kind of wave of anger and recruit
retribution
against these people because they are
seen not as critics not as dissenters
not as people who are wrong who need to
be persuaded but as enemies who have to
be taken out
yeah and dinesh i think it also opens
the door to physical attacks too
because you know the left is always
claiming that right wing
rhetoric you know inspires this or that
group
but what about their rhetoric i mean if
you're truly like hitler stalin mao
paul pot or whatever their you know
comparison is of the day
then gosh they're like mass murderers
conservatives who supported trump
i mean that's where this goes logically
well i think in the old communist states
it was simply the state that carried out
ultimately the recriminations the
violence but in this case the left seems
to be counting on the kind of alliance
of media digital moguls corporate
uh sponsors to work together with the
left so that ultimately they can expose
people
target them get them kicked off and made
into public non-persons
and at the end of the day who knows
unleash the deep state against them
perhaps
well dinesh they're already doing this
though right they've already
waged their war and academia i mean
you're not going to get a promotion in
most schools
if you're a well-known trump supporter
you're not going to get tenure in most
schools
you're not going to get an elevation in
the military probably in some
some cases if you're if you're known to
believe uh
in certain traditional values so a lot
of this is happening
but she's just being really vocal about
it
absolutely i saw in my own case years
ago sitting across from these obama
prosecutors that if they could they
would have locked me up for 10 years on
a minor technicality
because they didn't see me as a critic
they didn't see me they saw me
ultimately as an enemy
and that's the kind of poisonous
mentality that the left is putting into
the public discourse
even justifying it just justifying it in
academia
justifying it in media and ultimately it
carries over to the government
dinesh thank you so much perfect person
to talk about this tonight